you
[Music]
so the literate programmer so first just
a little background on on what this idea
is so I think it's important for
programmers to be literate and that
they've like read the classics or like
no history in the same way that it's
important for people for citizens to
have like a shared culture and base to
work from so like to this end I've been
pulling together thoughts about
computing in history in particular with
respect to the technology that I use and
I don't have a sound card but I do have
a tiny letter so I like write these
things out every so often so before we
start actually I wanted to see if I
could compute the median age of the
audience here so if you are if you are
under 30 raise your hand
oh is that about half was that actually
the median all right I'm just gonna
claim this the median okay so so so so
that means that you you started your
your career probably probably around
2008 and the stuff that I may be talking
about primarily centers before 2008 and
and then kind of goes a little bit past
that so it might be uh you know some
things that you haven't heard it before
okay how do I go to the next slide
oh the clicker aha oh that's that's
fanciness all right I can't figure this
one out either
who writes computer programs for a
living here okay okay so so I'd like to
start to talk here so this is Paul
hunting camp so he's done it several
notable things he's well-known and if
you in the freebsd community he's like
build technology that is probably taught
you in ways that you don't even realize
even if you're not a freebie user so
he's done many things but I'd like to
sort of call out three things and then
I'll go into depth on one of them so
first is that he and Rob Watson came up
with FreeBSD jails so this is the first
widely used container implementation and
this was some sometime around 2000
Solaris followed with zones
than five Linux cgroups which is a
predecessor to containers and docker was
in 2007 and then doctor itself was in
2013 so this is 13 years doctor came 13
years after jails and using FreeBSD
jails there were actually companies that
would allow you to rent slices of
computing time that was before Linode
and Xen and I was before before Amazon
ec2 second thing is he invented the term
bike shedding and it you know it means a
cacophony of opinions that surround the
most trivial of proposals the basic idea
here is that the more trivial something
is the more likely someone knows
something about it and so so the more
likely that they'll come up with some
argument or have an opinion you know but
he said we need a bike shed it doesn't
matter what color and the final thing is
this varnish so this is probably thing
that everyone here has has heard over or
had to deal with at some point so this
is a reverse caching proxy so what is a
reverse caching proxy yeah yeah like I
always thought that this is kind of a
funny name because it's it's relative
sort of to your point of view but in the
in the in the olden days companies would
have to run these proxy systems so every
every request that started internally
inside of a company's network would have
to pass through some machine it so this
was for performance and security reasons
and you know they called this machine of
proxy so right so that was that was
always like an Minh to mediate staff
that the requests had to have to move
through to leave the office now a a
reverse proxy is the opposite of this
the requests start from outside of the
network can come come in and so this is
the form of proxy that you're you
probably know about and and this is the
form that varnish takes on in the old
days there's this thing called squid I'm
guessing most people here have probably
not used squid but it was a it was an
immensely popular generates your hand if
you use squid okay so like let's say
less than a tenth of the people here
right so it was first written as a proxy
so it took requests that came from
inside of the network going out and then
they threw in some features they threw
in caching so if people were asking for
the same request over
again squid would just return that and
squid could also mess with headers and
stuff so you know it's like in like a
nice piece of software but because squid
caches these requests it had to keep
track of what memory it was using very
carefully and had to know because in
these days systems didn't have a lot of
memory it had to know when to move these
objects from disk into memory and back
because I had these features they
figured ok we can also make this thing a
reverse proxy right so requests coming
from the outside which is use a lot of
the same code so you know so this is
great for for performance someone from
the outside is asking for an object
inside of your system you don't want to
be contacting your web server over and
over again you just have squid respond
for you so so this is where varnish
comes in so pH K is varnish caching
reverse proxy competes with squid just
for the reverse proxying use case so he
looked at the design of squid right and
he and you looked at how squid was
messing with all the memory and he
thought you know all this logic is
actually it's actually done inside of
the OS so why should we have it in the
application as well and so so he wrote
this this this thing this 1975
programming was a very opinionated essay
welcome back to the head in a sec ok so
what did he mean by by the operating
system just doing all the lobbies of
squids doing ok so if you use a high
level language like Python or Ruby or
Java your customs are thinking about
memory allocation in terms of object
allocation all right so you say ok I
need enough memory to hold an instance
of class X ok if you go down one one
level of abstraction you'll find that
these objects are actually represented
by contiguous arrays of bytes so in
Sealand you don't ask for these objects
but instead you you you ask for multiple
chunks of contiguous bytes of possibly
different sizes and so so it turns out
so ram ram and the computer is
essentially a single big array of bytes
and so the question is ok how do you get
from the application to asking for a
small chunk oh by
it's too carving it out from rim now
it's uh it's bad when you have several
programs that are trying to run
simultaneously right so you don't wait
did I just like skipper hold on sorry
okay yeah sorry
so um so how do you carve these bites
off from RAM okay so so in the old days
what would happen is that programs would
share the same address space right so
this meant that the computer knows what
Ryan is Scott you know and it could be
accessed from BIOS bytes let's say 0
through 65,000 and when your program
runs they can start reading and writing
memory uh wherever it wants and so this
is fine if there's a single program on a
single machine and if you want to
program in embedded systems like the
Arduino this is still something that
happens but it's bad when there are
multiple programs that are trying to
access brain at the same time so you
would like to protect these programs of
from each other so so imagine that
you've got this array of bytes and you
have two programs that start up and
suppose you can allocate some bytes to
one program and some ways to another so
so program a says eye 1-800 ice and the
operating system says ok great you can
take bytes zero through seven
ninety-nine and the B says I want a
thousand bytes in the OS is great you
can take bytes 800 through 1799 and a
again comes back and says ok now and you
know now I need 30 more bytes in the OSS
okay great take 1802 1829 so now what we
have is application a owns bite zero
through seven ninety-nine
in 1803 1829 and then B owns eight
hundred through 1799 but how do these
these programs figure out like which
which bytes are there's like how do they
keep track of this like what is out kind
of a structure looks like and then what
happens when a program a releases zero
through seven ninety-nine and then tries
to access it again
right it's like how do you keep track of
these free Trunks chunks and then what
happens if program a actually tries to
access B's memory so how does the
operating system know so there are lots
and lots of questions here so what
happened was in in the in the mid 80s we
invented another layer of abstraction
called virtual dressing and with some
help from the CPU some some hardware
support we just totally swept this mess
out of the room
so in the Intel line of processors this
happened around the 386 and so with with
virtual addressing what happens is that
we change the way that programs
understand their memory so previously
two programs might share the same sort
of array of bytes the same physical
array of bytes but now with virtual
addressing they're both assigned to
seemingly infinite sequences of bytes
that's both start at zero so both
programs have a raise of memory that
started at 0 but what if two programs
want to access the thing that's a zero
so if we don't want those those two
bytes to actually be the same physical
bytes and so what virtual addressing
says is the OS will keep track of
mapping a program of mapping program a's
by zero to physical address say by 4096
in ram and then program B's
zero index to a different physical
address let's say by 8,192 so with this
in place it means that we we can perform
some neat tricks so so okay so first the
tracking of which chunks of memory or
program goes who's become a problem of
the OS and out of the application so
this simplifies the application since
they could just assume that it's got
this this trade up space starting at 0
stretching to infinity and then the OS
doesn't have to assign a mapping from
one virtual address to RAM until it's
actually needed and the third thing is
that a virtual address doesn't even have
to point a location in memory so this is
super cool right it could it could point
to some location somewhere else like on
disk all right so that's swap or even on
some machine that's connected by a
network so it's having the stuff on disk
is neat but accessing a bite off of disk
is really really slow compared to memory
and you know of course the network is
even slower so this is a pretty famous
table I think this is this Peter Norvig
wrote these years ago it's on his
website somewhere so you can see so
third from the bottom is the time to
fetch a new disk a new disk location to
seek so that's 8 milliseconds the these
days
rotational hard drives are I think
around three milliseconds and then an S
she's around 0.1 millisecond so you know
so these numbers aren't entirely
accurate right but this is a that's the
gist of it and if you look at where's it
fetched from main memory so 1 2 3 4 5 6
from the top it's a hundred nanoseconds
so polling data from disk is four orders
of magnitude slower than identify memory
so it's a really really big deal so so
yeah so you you can you you can kind of
trick the program with your thinking
that it has more RAM that it does by
programs aren't expecting the access to
ram to be so SS slows disk so so the OS
has to do this kind of a tricky thing of
taking bites on disk and the migrating
them it's in memory and creating a new
mapping behind the programs back again
there are some tricks for optimizing
this it can for instance do this in bulk
so that the these sort of average times
for moving for access it's a something
that's a disk isn't isn't so bad right
that's that's called paging and we'll
talk more about that all right so in C
land you're allowed to ask for arbitrary
size chunks of memory so imagine over
the course of a long-running program all
right yes you you may ask for chunks of
different sizes freedom ass for you free
them up as four more chunks the same
sizes or different sizes and over time
your memory starts to look like Swiss
cheese with holes in it like this so
like burn this into your brain because
this will actually become important
later
sometimes programs don't have to ask for
lots of arbitrary sizes of memory so
suppose for instance you have a three
flight simulator and you've got a lot of
instances of a type called point and a
point consists of X Y Z floating point
coordinates so all of these things are
the same size so you might imagine you
could write some kind of a specialized
memory allocator that's really optimized
for points if you have a precise
definition of what a point is so so this
is domain knowledge that the operating
system doesn't have so we need to be
able to push this kind of memory
allocation logic into the app but what
is the OS supposed to do when the app
asks for something as specific as like
27 bytes of memory
so the trick here is actually that the
app is not allowed to ask for behind for
27 bytes of memory instead what the app
does is it asks for entire pages of
memory so a page is basically a fixed
size array of bytes and is usually
something around 4 K so the program says
okay I need a page of RAM the US says
sure here it is go nuts and it is up to
the program to figure out how to split
that 4 K into 27 by trunks or whatever
size it needs so so how a program
decides to carve that up is a subject
for a different talk these things are
called memory alligators and there are
lots of different versions it's not well
known but in in its the C program in
UNIX you can actually replace these
alligators you know which is cool you
you you can pick different alligators
for different performance
characteristics so so the OS doesn't
deal with these arbitrary chunks of data
instead it just deals with pages and
this is a much easier bookkeeping
problem so you can just keep a keep a
list of free pages and you know pages
that just assigns a tabs
you take these pages and like I
mentioned before we can migrate them
onto disk when they're not being
accessed and it can bring them back into
memory when you know when it thinks that
I need some the OS can also it can guess
when it's safe to Jackson page of from
Ram to disk and when I might want to
prefetch some page from disk into RAM
and so that in a sense is the squid
problem right we need to make guesses as
to which objects in squid or pages in
the OS are frequent frequently accessed
to make sure those things stay in past
Ram so so another thing of note is that
the API is a tram and disk exposed to
the OS or in pages in terms of pages
anyways so so it gets to pass through
some of the access logic and also get
special hardware support around pages so
like for instance the CPU can tell a
program if a pro can tell the OS if a
program tries to access a page that
actually does not exist so so Phe Phe K
he looked at all this and he figured ok
why difficut the work right well throw
out all the memory management logic from
squid and instead we'll use the OS
paging mechanisms and make sure this
stuff floats fast and he's got this
history of writing some of the tories
emails and he laid out the architecture
of varnish this 2006 essay which
said that he wanted to bring a 1975
style program squid to 2006 style
architecture so he basically said okay
just let the OS do the hard memory stuff
and varnish and the double way
outperforming squid for reverse proxy
caching squid has gotten better since
then
but it's basically too late like I don't
know of anyone who actually runs squid
these days it's basically all varnish
all of fastly in a CDN for instance is
powered by varnish all right so
fast-forward to roughly 2008 2009 and we
see the new hot database on the market
it's MongoDB okay so MongoDB was was
built by a company called called Tenjin
actually no that's not quite right it
was a it was a it was a set it was it
was a component in a set of tools I was
yank yank from a company called shop
wiki so shop wiki has one of the most
dastardly clever business models that
I've ever come across
just so you know I'm not sure they still
exist but with like what they used to do
is they would buy up misspelled domains
and then when you went to one of these
misspelled domains they could generate
an online store like right on the fly
based off of a cute if you have some
keywords that they extract on the
domains but I'm curious if basically
browser domain autocomplete like just
killed this company off but they had
this this great web development platform
which included a database right and they
saw it okay let's spin off this web dev
platform in two entirely separate
companies so that's 10 gen after some
problems trying to sell though the
entire platform engine discovered
actually that the database was immensely
popular and it was easy it was it was it
was the only part of the platform that
had real consistent usage so they
focused just on that and so a couple
years ago they made the transitions that
are symbolically complete by renaming
their company to MongoDB so just just a
note for the rest of this this this talk
I'm focusing on [ __ ] pre version 3 so
the things that I mentioned here are all
things that [ __ ] no longer cares about
they've solved a lot of these issues all
right so so [ __ ] is a document story
actually I'm curious how many people
have used [ __ ]
ok so quite a few like at least half
okay so it's a document store which
under their definition is basically it's
a it's a JSON objects with with unique
IDs plus some secondary index
functionality so right so this comes
from their documentation this is a
document that you put into the database
it has a unique ID which is the
underscore ID field and then everything
else is a schemas it's it's a pretty
freeform so really the key part here is
that [ __ ] really thought of themselves
as a fancy key value store right the key
being the underscore ID and the document
itself being the value and so the design
of that meant that for instance things
like secondary indexes actually lagged
behind the primary the primary index
slightly you know and they did things
like they bolted on a MapReduce
framework and then they replaced that
with an aggregation framework and they
added charting but none of this work
really came from an initial sort of
cohesive theoretical design it was
things that they that they thought the
market was asking for and was useful in
the market Siegel in contrast was
theoretically defined in the 70s and
then had a decade of experimentation
before it reached Postgres and then
another decade before it reached my
sequel so there's a there's a very big
difference in like the speed of the
development of the you know the of the
ideas in these two systems so [ __ ] they
they latched on to the big data movement
and at this time it was not really a
thing that was parodied it was like a
real thing right and they you know they
got this name [ __ ] from the word
humungous right and they implemented a
memory management model a lot like the
one that we see in varnish right and in
fact I I wasn't able to verify this but
I believe even in their documentation
somewhere they they linked to the
varnish stocks so they made the same
argument and that modern OS memory
management is better than manually
handling memory in the application okay
so so it turns out four key value stores
like varnish the algorithm the OS uses
to efficiently handle this page movement
is something called least recently used
and this actually works pretty well in
practice so so the question is ok when
the OS has to move a page from disk into
RAM and
move a page from rim out to disk how
does it pick which page and ran to eject
so so so this algorithm says ok order
all the pages by the last time that they
were accessed and eject the one that was
accessed the longest ago so in other
words keep pages in Ram that look like
they keep getting accessed so this is
generally very good for varnish so web
pages most recently accessed are likely
to be access again and for [ __ ] as a
Cavey store it's probably good as well
right the documents most recently looked
up will probably be looked up again ok
why is it bad for [ __ ] so for secondary
indexes so scanning across a range of
documents or looking up data not on
recency LRU turns out to actually be a
bad thing
so Michael Stonebraker in 1981 argued
and you know and also in subsequent work
in the 80s by a count away they show
that manually managing memory and disk
accesses gives better performance and
letting the OS take care of it so just a
side note Michael Stonebraker is the the
the grandfather of database
implementations his team developed the
architecture not just for modern sequel
but also for column stores like verdict
and redshift and now a memory optimized
systems like both DB so why is LRU bad
for secondary indexes ok so this is the
intuition so on secondary on a secondary
index lookup right so your your
documents are usually not ordered by
last time access or they're ordered by
some property of the document that is
independent of the time that the
document was accessed so ok so here's an
example so suppose that you you have
this this collection of documents that
contains website user information right
so for instance you've got these uh
these four users here the dot that
actually is supposed to represent lots
and lots of other users but I'm just
under showing these and the different
colors represent different pages so ID
1000 and 1001 are in the same chunks of
memory and 999 is in a different chunk
right but all the things that there were
more things that were blue there would
all be the same
same chance so don't forget to that that
chunks of memory are pulled in in fixed
size pages one at a time okay so the the
ID increases on every new user so new
documents are ordered in the pages in
the order in which users sign up I
suppose that we have a page in which we
like to we like to list all of the users
right so we want to show that say the
first 100 users alphabetically so what
we do is we build a secondary index on
the user name and we do a range query
ordered by the user name and we limit
that to 100 so under the the naive let
memory handle its strategy we look up
Alice first we and that would pull in
the entire green page then Bob that
would pull in the entire blue page which
you know that doesn't sound so bad but
what happens if another request comes in
right at this instance and the OS
decides to switch to loops sorry and and
the OS decides to switch to that when
you give it a bit of CPU time so it's
possible sorry I'm losing all of my
notes so it's it's possible it's
possible that this process will need
some some memory and that the OS will
have to evict a page from RAM and it
send that to disk so if it uses if he
uses LRU then and the green page is the
oldest page it'll move that into this so
then let's say that we switch back to
the original request right and we have
to look up the contents of Carol so this
brings the green items back into memory
and so this moving of stuff to and from
disk is really expensive right it's four
it's four orders of magnitude slower
than just trying to access memory so
even if it doesn't happen very often
when it does happen it's very expensive
but uh not all is lost with some effort
the database can actually be smart about
tracking this location of these
documents and you can figure out okay
you know I know two of my objects are
Alex and Carol and they're in the same
page so when I look up Alice I should
also go ahead and look up Carol and then
I can look up Bob and sort the results
in memory later all right what's more is
if if the database can guess that it'll
need blue right after green then it can
fetch green start sorting green in
memory and then at the same time
such blue so notably this kind of
prefetching behavior is something that
only the application has a shot at
predicting right so the OS understands
nothing about the contents of the green
and blue pages so MongoDB they decide
they decided to believe phk and not
Stonebraker which was a technical
mistake and that's because [ __ ] thought
of itself as a Cavey store not as a
database okay and then Foursquare so
there was an infamous Foursquare outage
in 2010 and this was it was epic and and
an extreme extreme kudos to [ __ ] and to
Foursquare for being so public about it
I mean it sounds like I'm like really
complaining about [ __ ] quite a bit but
I consider this post-mortem to be one of
the most important things for modern web
developers to read so so Foursquare went
dark for 11 hours and is because one of
their manga databases exceeded the
amount of RAM that was available on the
machine so the OS paging mechanism
started to call it cause performance
issues and I made a huge subset of
queries uh very very slow so Foursquare
they figure this out and then they
brought up a new [ __ ] instance and
started to migrate some of this data off
to you know in some attempt to alleviate
the pressure on the main database makes
sense right to their surprise it didn't
actually help so why is that it's a
Swiss cheese problem so in the post
mortem [ __ ] explained that this is
because of the memory allocation
strategy so so as documents moves off
one server into into another [ __ ] would
free that that small chunk of memory but
because all these documents are slightly
different sizes not much of the memory
actually became free and reused and so
we saw this with the Swiss cheese
pattern in the memory allocator so not
just that but the the OS paging
mechanism brings an entire page in and
out of memory regardless of how much of
that page is actually being used so even
if all but one of the documents in the
page gets migrated off right as soon as
the database needs that one last
straggler the entire page comes back in
right and so the bytes required two
bytes loaded ratios very low [ __ ]
itself might know which pages are not
being used efficiently and be able to do
something but at the time they were
using they were using a memory allocator
that actually behaved a lot like just
standard memory allocation and then they
they let the OS handle the pages so it's
a [ __ ] didn't have the capability to do
this so so so don't forget right so
smart behavior depends on the
application logic and the standard
allocators don't have that than that
logic or that knowledge so the fix for
this problem was essentially to rewrite
all of the documents in place and
thereby removing all of the empty space
and you know if your java person i this
this this looks a lot like stop and copy
garbage collection which is what happens
in your eat-in space okay so there's
there's some some irony in this because
because manga was marketed as being able
to handle huge amounts of data right but
more accurately it could handle a lot of
kt lookups and so this was a case where
the memory architecture chosen for
performance and scale reasons was
precisely why it failed alright so I'll
quickly contrast this to a system like
Postgres right so Postgres does two
things that are relevant here the first
is that it manages the pages very
carefully and on a query on a secondary
index it plans out the sequence I just
going to fetch the pages off disk and
then the second thing is that every row
in Postgres is the same size and bytes
so this is a direct consequence of
having a well-defined schema so that
that points example I gave like in the
flight simulator you can imagine it's
easy to write a special optimized
especially optimized allocator if you
know that every request is going to be
for the same size but poor [ __ ] is
scheme ulis and and so every record
could be could be a different size all
right so so there's an the technical
part of this talk and dive into some
some ethics okay so it's it's it's
unfair to expect that [ __ ] really knows
what you what your usage pattern is and
it's and and and it's actually in in
general it's a very hard problem to be
able to define one model that works for
for most applications my beef with all
of this has to do with the marketing
around the project so so I think there a
couple of things in play here so the
first is that [ __ ] transition from a
dog food database into vc-backed
adventure all right second thing is that
data is inertia the third thing is that
10gen didn't have any big data use cases
so the the the incentive structures for
vc-backed companies are to go big or
bust right so and there's you know
there's also this this the general trend
you know I'm sure you've seen all the
senior companies that you first you
adopt tech that's open source and then
maybe you'd optech that's free but
closed source and then maybe you pay for
stuff that's closed source so so
Stonebraker looked at this and he and he
argues he argues us about all new
database projects both DB included was
that a database vendor the only way that
they can really stay in business these
days is if they offer their software for
free fries and beer at least to
accumulate a wide base of users and then
they monetize a small number of those
users so point number one means that
mongos strategy right is to make the
thing popular not to design it well so
why wouldn't you just switch off of
[ __ ] right because the point number two
it's really hard right so by the time
you're at scale and you see cracks in
the design you've adopted an entirely
unique data model sorry so no other
database quite matches [ __ ]
unlike sequel for which there are
multiple competing systems and you have
a lot of you know and yeah you know then
you have a lot of options right so it's
really hard to migrate not only the data
but to also portray application so
there's an effect a kind of data lock in
even though among itself is free as in
freedom data is inertia so early
adoption plus vendor lock-in me means
growth numbers look good and that's what
we see so on and the third thing is
among has stopped getting dog food and
as a result something like force the
Foursquare outage happens I'm eating
like like like if you think about like
what actually happened here right
Foursquare responded to a full database
by adding another node which is exactly
a completely reasonable and expected
thing to do right and and then they lost
their cluster for 11 hours right
undoubtedly tendrán had tests on
bringing up extra nodes right but they
somehow
sat on this very real-world failure case
but what about the ethics of consumers
like you and me our tendency is to use
fries and beer stuff and then uh you
know grab software and not pay is what
actually dries software vendors to VC
growth models or is that there's a
similar thing going on with media right
so the tendency to read only free
content drives publishers towards
advertising models like they want lots
of eyeballs and it'll monetize a small
set and you know and it just it just
kind of aligns the business in a weird
in weird ways right so as a consumer you
want to make sure that you're that
you're paying for quality and some I'm
sorry that your your your you're paying
your vendor in some way that encourages
quality all right so so so free content
incentivizes lots of eyeballs with low
conversion rates it also encourages
freemium models right so which I think
for a database system is incredibly
problematic the popular strategy is okay
what features would a big company pay
for so let's say like multi data center
replication and let's let's charge for
those features right but there's small
set of companies that need that too I'm
sorry there are small companies that
need that as well right so withholding
that feature is kind of like saying you
know nice data you got there would be a
shame if something happened to it
then there's convenience so so I think I
think Starmaker
misses this point so it's not just that
the software is free but that the
software is convenient and I think we
have a tendency a sovereign errors and
just maybe in general on the internet to
really go for convenience right and so
to you know we figure well we'll move
fast and they'll work things out later
developers like residents are accustomed
to to to downloading installation
scripts and piping them directly into
into a shell I mean like like how like
how lazy do you have to be just allow
anybody here I hate to have sudo access
to your machine and there's this weird
dev culture of like of laziness being a
virtue um so for instance Larry wall the
creative pearl he says it's one of three
virtues of programmers and like really
taken without nuance that's that's good
that's you know I think that's kind of a
horrendous virtue and finally I you know
I think we as software developers we
have to be ok talking about failures
I'm particularly thinking about failure
of our own systems right the the
Foursquare post-mortem is great like
these these kinds of course modem post
mortems are becoming more common but I
don't think that they really go into the
amount of technical depth that they
should and you know and I think that we
have an ethical responsibility to be
more more open about our failures all
right so I'll end with this guy price
this is Richard Fineman um so so science
is about failure and and he and he talks
about how the core of the scientific
method is the ability and the
responsibility to actively try to
disprove your own ideas not just those
of others right so Fineman says so right
so he talked about the difference
between science and science in
advertising by by illustrating a Wesson
oil advertisement right which claims
that that that their oil doesn't soak
through food so phiman points out yes
this is this is indeed true but actually
no oils soaked through food if operated
at a certain temperature so if operated
at a different temperature all oil
soaked through food or so so he says
that's the difference between marketing
and engineering so the marketer says our
database is designed for big data that's
technically true but the engineer should
say we've never tested it beyond X right
Fineman he talked about a civilization
in the South Seas that became accustomed
to receiving supplies from Western
nations during wartime then when the war
stopped and the plane stopped coming
they participated in rituals in some
attempts to get those planes to come
back right so they made fake headphones
with fake sticks and they went out to
empty landing strips and they made like
all of the motions of landing crews
thinking like that's that's the thing
that got the planes to come and firemen
calls this cargo cult science right it's
it's the it's emotion or participation
in what seemingly science but really
lacks something fundamental and you know
he talks a bit about the history of the
oil-drop experiment where science
scientists would throw out their
replications if it didn't match the
previous results but it turns out that
the very first experiment was wrong and
it took decades for us to get the charge
of an electron correct
because we kept throwing out all of
those like all the results that didn't
match and kept kept the ones that did so
the scientific community talks openly
about problems with incentive structures
encouraging bad signs the system is
incentivized to produce positive results
like through publishing journals getting
accepted into conferences him but real
progress actually depends as much on
negative results as it does from
positive results but the system is
rigged really in favor of those who
produce positive results so I I think I
think you know in a way we're in a
golden age of cargo called open source
if we have these communities that are
largely driven by incentive schemes
which distort open source community
driven development and acknowledging
this is happening I think it's a first
step towards fixing it but even science
as it has you know like this doesn't
have it figured out either so I think as
doves of open source and as users of
open source like we we have to be be
honest that our actions may actually be
distorting the proud of the true process
of open source so phiman says the first
principle of illuminating cargo cult
science is that you must not fool
yourself he also talks about a second
principle which it doesn't actually
enumerate in his essay but he says that
as a scientist um you need to have the
integrity to bend over backwards to give
all the information right to explain how
you might be wrong and how your data may
point to a different conclusion then how
our experiment fails so he says the
first principle is to not fool yourself
and I will add that the second principle
is not to to fool others so as
developers we should first have to knock
for ourselves and then we can't fool
others so I think if you if you write
code for a living closer open you should
ask okay am I allowed to be honest can I
provide the information total and
complete about how my system worked so
well and poorly when was the last time
that you went to an open source project
to write to their landing page and saw
links to blog posts about how it failed
maybe like there's there's there's no
there's no shame in leaking to failure
like you should it makes a project
stronger and it gives engineers
something to solve and there's a there's
a third principle that I've been
thinking about as well which cross cuts
a bit with the the computational social
science that I do at court
in like in the Media Lab um so recently
I came across work by Ileana Mason who's
a political scientist at the University
of Maryland College Park she talks about
polarization and identity politics
um actually argues that politics becomes
contentious when technocratic ideas
become intertwined with the person's
identity so if your identity is
indistinguishable from for instance guns
or transgenderism then a technical
debate about gun policy or about the
definition of gender becomes an attack
on your identity for open-source
developers especially project founders
the software is a part of their identity
and I think some of this is true for
single companies as was you know as well
like [ __ ] I mean like [ __ ] renamed
itself [ __ ] so we should aim to
criticize ideas and not people but this
becomes difficult if the idea itself is
tied up in the people and like in the
identity [ __ ] was never really a
community it was it was never really
community around to the same extent
that's a Python is so even though Python
up until recently had a BD FL the
project set up this this pep process
that focus on the debate of ideas and
not on identities the entire conceit of
the Apache foundation is to move a
project from its founders into a
sustainable community the 0 mq c 4
process is one that prioritizes
empowering the community over
centralized control so I suspect that a
an idea oriented governance structure is
something that as consumers we should
look for and something that project
founders should aspire to create and I
think an engineering or should strive to
have an idea right they had this idea
oriented governance structure as well so
if an engineer's identity is tied
closely to a subsystem then the failure
of that system becomes an attack on that
individual and I found in my own work
it's harder for me to admit my failures
you know to have integrity if if I'm the
only committer but if I have coke
emitters it's a team effort and it's
about the integrity of the code and we
work through the technical issues and
it's not my personal pride that's hurt
when something breaks ok so all and this
talk in the same way that fine
sorry that finally ended his he said I
wish to you the good luck to be
somewhere where you are free to maintain
that the kind of integrity
I've described and where you do not feel
forced by need to maintain your position
in the organization or financial support
or so on to lose your integrity may you
have that freedom thanks ru [ __ ]
employee know I know if you know so you
mention was 0 mq and appache and the
Python project structure is there any
sort of gold stand it's not anyone you
can point to that say yep this is how we
should do it what they're doing it
better than the rest yeah that's a great
question I don't I don't personally know
I mean I'm like trying to figure this
out I'm doing some sort of personal
exploration here but I mean I think I
have a I really like to see for ideals
in the process quite a bit but I don't
know of really any other major projects
that use it except for 0 mq so in in my
mind it's it's very philosophically
clean and pure but possibly untested
Apache of course it's Apache right this
there's clear success there but I I
don't know from the outside like I also
feel like Apaches a bit they'll just let
any project in like as long as there's a
community governs its structure right
and so as a consumer of Apache stuff it
becomes it becomes quite confusing so
yeah the short answer is I don't really
have a great idea of what's with the
optimal process and is there any way
that like a improperly managed let's say
project could transition to a properly
managed one I'm thinking specifically of
like what happened with BSD last year or
maybe it was earlier this year where a
bunch of my friends that were really
into it got really upset and stopped
being involved with the project because
of a change in their code of conduct so
what would what happen there I just
don't want to get into it ok alright I
think it's possible I mean a lot of
these these projects said well you know
as your omq is a good example right so
it's a zero mq
had more like a centralized control
structure going for it and then if I'm
recalling the story correctly there was
actually like essentially revolt and
there was a fork of the project we're
not quite a fork but like every
implementation of something and and and
at that point they decided to go with
the c-4 process and won it like the key
feature c4 is that they they prioritize
anybody being able to commit and merge
into master over like a more sort of a
structured process by which you like go
through testing and things with the idea
that if you can merge in quickly you can
fix things quickly and what they noticed
was that when they put the c4 process in
developers were much more engaged they
contributed a lot more code and there
was a larger number of dads as well and
there Clayton too is that the quality
the software went out I'm not sure how
they measured that but you know like I
would just trust them thank you thanks
for the talk this might be a tangent
what is your opinion about the Linux
kernel and this idea of identity being
intertwined with the wall in this case
it's like the identity of the person is
closely real you know related to the
quality of the software over multiple
decades and then he had to take a
sabbatical and the code of conduct
changed but it's kind of like if he
wasn't that person who kind of didn't
reinforce those rules maybe you wouldn't
have to lose kernel right right yeah oh
yeah that's a great question so I you
know I think there are clearly some
problematic things about Linda's
Torvalds personality which is what she's
working through and you know have been
like known publicly for a while as far
as as far as like participation and
structure of the of the the actual
source code though I think Linda's he I
shouldn't say that he like really like
removed his identity from the project
but it was definitely like for you know
for a long time for instance he's had a
set of lieutenants right and he'll he'll
offload a lot of like things like
maintaining stable branches to other
people I think he he recognized at some
point that it
it really the way that he ran the
project he he would he would have to be
able to accept a lot more contributions
right and run it more like a community
ignoring personality problems sort of
driving people away from you know from
the community
[Music]